final final question I read an itty with
you in 2019 that said fifty percent of
your net wealth is in Bitcoin probably
regret saying that actually where it's
today
yeah so I've never started a Bitcoin I
don't know what the numbers are today in
fact I've bought more Bitcoin but in my
whole thought process here is I'm
relatively young compared to most people
right and the other thing people never
ask me is like what do I do with the
rest
it's either cash or real estate right
and so for the most part I'm pretty
risk-averse with half my portfolio I'm
obviously very risky with the other half
kind of a barbell strategy given my age
kind of my risk tolerance level it
actually makes a lot of sense
you're diversified even though a
significant chunk of your wealth of
course anything if you look right and
you know again when I talk to kind of
traditional investors so how much of
your wealth is in dollar denominated
stocks for example so when we have a day
like yesterday we had where the stock
market draws down you know a material
percentage for the for the ball today
that it's used to all of a sudden you
may have 50 60 70 80 % of your wealth
that's all in one single asset class
right I'm individual companies are
different and all that but you're still
exposing yourself to a similar risk
level in terms of everything is
correlated it's all gonna move together
bitcoins no different it just happens to
be that I've made a very calculated
investment decision and one that I'm
willing to be comfortable and live with
well reconvene in 2021 when it's a
hundred thousand awesome thank you so
much